CBS News confirms it paid a secret nine
and a half million dollar settlement to
an actress this year after she accused
the star of the hit show bull of
harassment Eliza Dushku was written off
CBS as a whole after she confronted
Michael Weatherly about his behavior
according to a new report in The New
York Times The Times says the details
were revealed in a draft report from
lawyers hired by CBS's board to
investigate the company's culture and
sexual misconduct allegations vladimir
duthiers our streaming network cbsn is
here with latest Vlad good morning good
morning The Times says when Eliza Dushku
appeared on bull last year there were
well-developed plans to make her a
full-time cast member but those plans
allegedly ended after she came forward
with allegations against the show's star
I need to know whose team you're on I'm
on your team obviously there is no other
team Eliza Dushku's time on CBS's hit
show wool is brief she played a lawyer
alongside the show's star Michael
Weatherly for just three episodes in
season one wait a second might be
released
well yeah according to a draft report
from lawyers hired by CBS's board and
reviewed by the New York Times Dushku
was written off the show
within days of confronting Weatherly
about behavior that made her
uncomfortable among the allegations he
told a rape joke and said in front of
the cast and crew that he would bend her
over his leg and spank her and in
another alleged incident onset Dushku
holds up three fingers during a scene
she allegedly told investigators whether
Lee suggested she wanted a threesome
with him and another male cast member I
don't know what to do with you well I
could think of a few things but you know
what
after being written off the show Dushku
entered mediation with CBS according to
the times that's when a lawyer for CBS
handed over outtakes from bull in belief
it would help their case but it
allegedly backfired
The Times reports the outtakes were a
gold mine that actually captured some of
the harassment CBS investigators
allegedly concluded the failure to
recognize the harassment was a symptom
of larger problems at the network the
network agreed this year to pay Dushku a
confidential settlement of nine and a
half million dollars roughly the amount
she would have earned as a series
regular eight months later when CBS
investigators approached her she
allegedly told them my story is true and
it's really affected me we reached out
to Dushku but she declined to comment
whether Lee did not immediately respond
to our request for comment but told The
Times he immediately apologized the
Dushku when she confronted him and he
realizes some of his language and
attempts at humor were not appropriate
he denied asking for her removal in a
statement CBS said the allegations in
douches claims are an example that while
we remain committed to a culture defined
by a safe inclusive and respectful
workplace our work is far from done
bianna all right glad thank you